the Joe Rogan experience you know that's
what's happening with snakes in the
Everglades do you know about that mm-hmm
- do you know about the Everglades nope
anacondas and pythons and [ __ ]
mostly pythons because dudes have as
pets and they let them go and either
finding them now there's 17 18 feet long
anacondas are Python Python 's [ __ ]
they're eating alligators they did a
study they deserve video that oh yeah
yeah their photos of it and this video
this video you can watch him eat an
alligator in Florida in Florida god yeah
they're giant and they're they're
infested so they did like a biological
survey of the Everglades and they were
down like 99% in some animals like deer
99% Marsh hair like like 98% 95%
raccoons that kind of [ __ ]
there are see there are they anything
are they killing people - oh they go
they for sure some [ __ ] rednecks have
disappeared and they just don't
guarantee a guarantee against take that
go if you wanted to get rid of somebody
man take them to Python country are they
population of these snakes is how much
you can do have you ever seen the
Everglade you did to set up traps do you
kidding
show jit show and probably services with
that kind of [ __ ] well there's too many
of them fifty thousand of what snakes
yeah there's over a thousand pythons
yeah yeah how did they count they have
rough estimates based on corn quadrants
so like what they'll do is they'll take
like and it's not it's not 100 cent
accurate they unless they tagged all of
them in which the case they're [ __ ]
it should just kill them but if you
cause they're an invasive species for
people don't know they're not from
Florida at all so they're just
devastating the ecosystem and they're
turning on alligators they're eating
alligators now because they basically
run out of everything else to eat it's
it's a crazy [ __ ] animal so what they
would do is they would take I would
guess like a chunk of the Everglades you
know a 100 square yards or something
like that and they'd measure the amount
and then they would do another one they
would they would do it like several
places and then take an average and then
calculate all the square footage and
that's why they'd be pro or con you
would think like hundreds of people
would have been killed already know
because I don't think that many people
first of all go in there and I don't
think they want to eat people I think
they probably don't know what the [ __ ]
person is
they see a rabbit or some other [ __ ]
that probably looks like food people are
wearing clothes I'm just guessing I know
they do jack people though overseas
there's been horrible videos of guys
getting cut out of giant snakes and
everything oh yeah I've seen that that's
crazy yeah some poor villager yeah woman
missing they find the snake and ago we
found her like I know they can this
[ __ ]
bounty hunter kills gargantuan Burmese
python gets 375 bucks and earns our
undying gratitude little sizing dude so
these things are Florida what like like
valence Everglades wherever the
Everclear so I am II the Everglades is a
giant ass Gulf side middle like the both
sides kind of depending it's like a big
swamp plan show Eddie an overhead view
of the Everglades because the Everglades
are [ __ ] bananas one thing that they
found that was interesting yeah [ __ ]
yeah so that all that stuff is dense
dense swamp
that's just monster soup the tip of the
dick of Florida is monster soup that's
what that is
you got some leaves you got some basil
[ __ ] snakes you got some grass you
got some [ __ ] growing out of the ground
and you got [ __ ] alligators and
snakes in a aliens vs. predator battle
to the death
oh how a Joey described Everglades
listen [ __ ]
these [ __ ] dirty white people with
this thinking oh you want a [ __ ]
snake what are you you're all on the
Wiccan get the [ __ ] the guy kicks his
[ __ ] kid out of the house the kid
can't feed the snake next thing you know
monster soup I mean it really is down to
these two super predators battling it
out to the death and right now I mean I
don't see any pictures of the alligators
eating the pythons do we have video of
alligators in pythons they're eating
each other okay so I guess it's good at
least everybody's eating everybody Jesus
got a whole deer in its body this
Florida same article Jesus Christ man
they can swallow a hold
that is so nuts they're not even as wide
as us imagine not being as wide as a
person and you could swallow a whole
deer it says it foul it had a 35-pound
white-tailed fawn in it
it was eating 111 percent o 11.1% don't
know 111 percent it was a 31 pound snake
eating at 35 pound deer oh my god oh my
god yeah they don't give a [ __ ] I didn't
read that part oh my god that is so
ridiculous yeah they can eat their whole
body where would you ever see that
you've seen that we've showed that video
of the Frog or it was a frog rat toe
that ate the mouse sure the mouse is
bigger than him bro he just [ __ ] eats
it he just I didn't know that toads did
that I had no idea this video this is
like the little white mouse is in this
cage just like looking around with this
frog and this frog just like slowly
comes close to him slowly comes closer
and then swap just half his body oh and
you see this mouse trying to kick and
get the [ __ ] out of there and then the
Frog just like slowly just chokes him
down I don't know I hate insects that's
what I thought too if they figured it
out see if people believe in evolution
right I believe in evolution if people
believe in evolution why do we think it
stops with us why don't we think these
goddamn frog is gonna take over maybe
like one of the first the first signs of
it was this Pepe the Frog controversy on
the Internet
maybe it's shots fired things to come
these frogs gonna start eating meat in a
trump Frog
maybe these frogs are eating meat that's
what's going on smarter Pepe the Frog
was that around before Channel
what is this Jaime oh I've seen this
rock as a snake it's about the snakes
yeah attacking a cat whoa oh the cat
comes over to swipe the [ __ ] snake
cats a ruthless bro cats a ruthless
[Applause]